welcome to this video um against ja ja
da promises netherlands yep okay um yeah
maybe it Sicilian okay so play the night
off hmm there's some way to get him out
of the one trodden path okay just
castles hmm ok maybe go for knight c6
trying to take on deform and then be
five we are now transposing to him I
guess the the cells in variation where
Bishop c4 is played them with a night
already being on c6 yeah this is a well
known position I believe actually with
taking b5 and there's a five and mmm ok
ok maybe I can also play this smoothly I
might maybe he can understand withdraw
on the night now my ideas of course to
take and play Bishop to c6
Jim maybe Knight f3 years a move
intending 'if I've trying to prove that
I should have taken first on d forearm
gone for a b5 set up okay i'm not sure
that 93 is really am tremendously
helpful okay i can now take it and play
97 is this is this okay I'll this was
the idea so let's let's do it if he goes
'if I've maybe I just play 97 not even
taking okay I can take okay I can take e
5 de I can take because he cannot take
with the poor now that's important as d4
hangs so what I what I must be a bit
cautious about us to get some sort of
position where he gets a 5 de five every
five my knight moves and then he goes
and I did say nitey for one night to
have six this kind of attacking play the
Sun is something well that I need to
need to prevent okay well here I could
play be five maybe I should do that
really I get the chance um and now
before before means he probably has to
go all the way back and to be one okay
well that shouldn't be too bad for me
shouldn't it if he go see five now I can
play 95 I believe so
okay how to play now and one day ever
should play 97 just voluntarily get it
to c5 that's not helping much
a four is not really leading to much
yeah tough the same this also gets the
idea is 65 into play which I think has
become a bit more interesting as the
night is on d to enter not on a square
like c3 where it could immediately up to
e5 okay p.m. activated the night down
hmm interesting
ya know if I've is not not all at all I
can play d 5 but mm does not look too
great okay i guess i need some some more
protection on them on the Kings side f5
this e 5 and he cannot easily play now
he five and then quickly f5 so after you
five I can play d 50 I can maybe take it
my experience in this kind of ravening
and positions are sir very limited and I
think it shows a bit always I had played
this like let's say 20 years ago or even
a bit longer but even back then I had my
my difficulties here we go p md5 don't
really know d5 of course you won't try
to swing the rock over
and no f5 is probably gaining enormously
in strength hmm i don't know this
probably was a bad idea
yeah its ideas of course to smash on age
7 in some way a badly need you five
maybe I should have played your five
right away okay well now I'm threatening
us maybe a bit bit bit much of a word
but well maybe he can play a queen h 5v
actually group g3 ok so he thought a d5
or something else
d5 looks very very passive maybe I can
play d5 night if only we didn't play 93
I really met a much expected 293 time
morning here I thought that this type of
position should be fairly resilient of
course it's dangerous oh that's clear
but I saw that down it should be fairly
stable still can I go my not really
Knight f6 to e4 would be would be nice
okay I'm trying it
Queen g6 Sam is a threat now but it's
just drawing at the moment if I believe
I'm correct just leading to a perpetual
oh really
I don't have a defense against this
William check no I'm just meet at him no
way to defend him this simply wasn't my
fence my Italian that wasn't a good
position really it was very difficult to
play I mean at some way i think i think
at some way at some point that maybe was
was ok again but here it just like wow i
thought this would be stable but in fact
it's losing directly queen III is very
strong him intending root page 7 played
this move now this Nagi is still okay
here but yeah the whole thing really
wasn't good I mean I'm pretty sure that
let's say up to this point I should be
okay it shouldn't be terribly bad but
exactly here I have a good move maybe
Bishop f6 is this a good move because II
five is not so easily playa volume now
with the bishop on c6 opposing the
rupiah then maybe d5 yeah this is
probably still quite okay computer says
equal yeah i'm not sure but at least i'm
not i'm not totally totally clobbered
here yeah after this the computer is
very skeptical about blacks chances ya
hear well I also my problem was that 96
had totally underestimated I was just
thinking about 93 which is not a totally
a terrible idea intending nygean
getting the night over them but this is
just much stronger now he's got both
bishops on the King side and yeah black
is lost here computers on plus form hmm
which is quite a lot hmm yeah sometimes
I'm playing all openings it's not
helping as you are not experienced
enough in the in the middle games around
here this was still ok but then I didn't
really find the right right way to go
and even that's what would have liked to
play e5 at some point to to make those
bishops um somewhat some wood worse but
ok I mean I must play Bishop f6 year
this is really much better alright
thanks for watching